it's the funniest thing my kids call me
a player i was like who taught you that
word
this is like who's been talking to you
and he's like dad
you can't be a player forever i'm like
and nick cannon's giving his
kids and the rest of the world even more
to talk about
the 39 year old is allegedly expecting
his fourth
child and get this it's not with his
current girlfriend
yep that's nick's three-year-old son
golden with ex brittany bell announcing
his big brother's status the former miss
arizona usa
posted the video back in june revealing
that she's
pregnant with her second child quote and
now you know we are so happy now here's
the thing
britney technically didn't reveal her
baby daddy
but when followers started
congratulating both her and
nick she did nothing to shut them down
in fact
she liked the comments then on july 7th
the 32 year old debuted her baby bump
with the caption cannonball nick hasn't
confirmed or denied the pregnancy news
i'm trying to fix myself i'm trying to
be the best me i could be the best dad i
could be
i'm really just focused on me and being
the best me because
for some reason i haven't gotten this
relationship thing right i'm not good at
it i don't like doing
stuff that i'm not good at meanwhile the
host's current girlfriend jessica white
who he's dated off and on since 2015
has been gushing about her man on
instagram most recently posting a sexy
black and white shot of the couple
with a cryptic caption quote catch me
don't let me drop keep loving me like
you do
don't ever stop hashtag myhero
thank you for all your support on my new
journey
my love hashtag no entanglements here
what's more the 36 year old responded to
a post revealing that britney's baby
was conceived when she and nick were on
a temporary break
in addition to nick and brittany's
three-year-old son golden
the comedian also shares nine-year-old
twins moreau and monrocken with
ex-wife mariah carey i made a lot of
people mad
canon's alleged baby news comes amid
major backlash from anti-semitic
comments
he made during an episode of his canon's
class podcast
last month poor question for everybody
in our community is
is he sincere is this real do you feel
sincere
at this point yes the comedian has since
been fired by viacom
cbs the network revealing this about the
future of his show
wilden out in a statement to et quote
while we support ongoing education and
dialogue in the fight against bigotry
we are deeply troubled that nick has
failed to acknowledge or apologize
for perpetuating anti-semitism and we
are terminating our relationship with
him
cannon fired back in a facebook post
writing he will not be bullied
silenced or continuously oppressed i
always say i i'm a hustler man
i got that mentality and that's not
canon's only project to be affected as a
result of his comments
the 39 year old's talk show which was
scheduled to launch in the fall
has been put on hold cannon also
announced that he's taking
some time away from his la based radio
show
nick cannon mornings i gotta live my
truth and i gotta speak my two